last week we did this story about megyn
kelly former fox news reporter megan
kelly choosing on her second episode of
her new NBC news network show choosing
to interview conspiracy theorist alex
jones and i said very clearly last week
i have no problem with people
interviewing alex jones i don't believe
in no platforming him however given all
the hubbub and the big deal that was
made about megyn kelly the great megyn
kelly leaving fox news and she's going
to have this tremendous show she gets an
interview with Vladimir Putin and it's
all extraordinary and fantastic and then
episode 2 of the show she interviews
Alex Jones so I said I just thought he
wasn't worthy of the platform now we did
a non-scientific poll at david
pakman.com I am NOT presenting this as a
perfectly sampled scientific poll of all
Americans it's merely a representative
view of people in our audience who chose
to vote saying what's your opinion of
megyn kelly decision to interview Alex
Jones on her new Network show 49% of our
audience agrees with megyn kelly
decision to interview Alex Jones
interesting 46 percent of our audience
disagrees with the decision some of whom
because they believe Alex Jones just
isn't notable enough for that platform
some people in our audience saying they
don't agree with megyn kelly decision to
interview Alex Jones because he is
offensive now what I think is the most
relevant thing we learned about this
interview is that in the end people
weren't that interested in it because it
got shockingly low ratings I ended up
not watching it at all I had other
things to do and it wasn't important
enough for me to turn it on and watch it
I've not watched it after the fact so
that actually is the most interesting
thing which was the news of the
interview generated controversy and Alex
Jones leaking his recorded phone calls
with megyn kelly during the
pre-production process got some
attention but in the end the ratings for
this interview were low and I think that
innocent
I am vindicated in that he's just not
worthy of the platform and people didn't
really care or I wonder if people were
protesting because they disagreed with
Megan Kelly's choice to interview him
and I mean
I think it was totally fine I think he
is relevant at this point because I mean
his YouTube channel has over a billion
views he has a big talk radio audience
as well and while he says offensive
things it's not as if he's doing the
offensive actions himself like you know
he denies the Sandy Hook shooting right
but he's not the Sandy Hook shooter okay
well Wow I mean if we've ever found a
silver lining that requires more of a
reach it's a Alex Jones didn't do Sandy
Hook I guess you're right I mean that's
Joe he didn't do Sandy Hook and that I
would definitely be different I like
that approach but it wasn't notable
enough for you to watch it right no I
haven't seen it yeah thank you supply or
attending the Vladimir Putin interview
either okay that's fair anyway so our
audience roughly split although for
different reasons between people who
believe it was a good idea and people
who believe it was not our new poll at
david pakman.com i encourage you to vote
now will Donald Trump fire Assistant
Attorney General rod Rosenstein that is
the current poll question at david
pakman.com you can vote there send me
your thoughts about it i'm on twitter at
D Pakman and of course you can follow
the show on twitter at david pakman show
today's episode made possible by taga
dabbe the hosting specialist taga tab
offers a range of flexible hosting
packages including dedicated VPS and
cloud server options they also do custom
server solutions and colocation services
taga dab has a really user-friendly
interface and excellent customer support
team their expert hosting specialists
also are their friendly support team and
they give customers full access to their
knowledge and service with over 70% of
taga DAB's business coming from repeat
orders and recommendations and a
Trustpilot review rating of nine point
seven out of ten you know that taga dab
takes their customer service very very
seriously with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects that the cloud
taga dad is offering you as a david
packard show viewer or listener a twenty
British Pound free credits about twenty
four US dollars to all new customers
signing up to give you a chance to try
their services
to take advantage of it go to sign up
tag adapt comm /p dps for more
information on their cloud VPS and
dedicated server features once again
sign up tag adapt comm slashed edps use
the discount code TDPS 20